this episode brought to you by
expressvpn the best VPN there is take
back your online privacy today
[Music]
it's show time
so it's finally come to this moving
killer tire
movie about a killer tire
probably heard that idea and had us in
what reaction I did which was but they
did it they made a movie about a killer
time
you might be asking yourself why they
make a movie about a killer tire but you
clicked on this damn video didn't you
you just answered your own question
after years and years of being asked to
review this stinker I'm finally gonna
give critic are you talking to us or the
viewers at home which one makes me look
more clever neither then either okay
yeah I just blew your mind and I if you
want to thank that yeah
any what I figure I explain what you're
about to see as an excuse to why it
exists isn't that like a poet explaining
what a poem is in the poem are you
peddling bad sounds even deeper maybe
you should just get to the review yeah
okay let's take a look at the film you
have to see to believe and you have to
believe to see
oh okay I get it go like this
I'm not we got it otherwise he's not
gonna start the review right
yeah I blew your mind
let's take a look at rubber
it may not be that nostalgic but I'm
sick to death of getting requests for it
so here it is an actual movie about a
killer tire released in 2011 rubber is
another one of those polarizing films
where critics seem to like it okay but
audiences felt very disappointed it's a
movie about a killer tire you dumbass is
quite frankly you deserve whatever movie
they give you there is no bar to meet so
is there a secret gem that's smarter
than it looks or is it so bad that even
people who pay to see a killer tire feel
let down again I don't know how you let
a crowd like that down well it might
sound strange but this film is worth a
deeper analysis so let's take a look at
critic why do we have to watch this from
a distance it's symbolic of what well if
you have to ask you clearly don't get it
I know that's why I asked he's so naive
he is such a jackass let's take a look
at rubber we open our film with you know
you have one job show attire that's a
chair I can see why people hated this
just when you're wondering if this is an
Ikea uprising a car shows up knocking
them all down so this is an Amish
driving test forget it buddy even that
amount of binoculars won't help you find
the plot a man in a cop uniform gets out
of the trunk and gets a glass of water
from the driver well I'll be following
this just fine
in the Steven Spielberg movie et why is
the alien Brown no reason in love story
why do the two characters fall madly in
love with each other no reason in the
pianist how come this guy has to hide
when he plays the piano so well at this
point the killer tire would be normal he
goes on explaining other random
questions from movies they have no
answers or maybe they do they're just
asked in really dumb ways in the
excellent Chainsaw Massacre by tobe
Hooper why don't we ever see the
characters go to the bathroom well I
can't account for the excellent Chainsaw
Massacre before the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre I think it's because the
director wasn't a sicko I mean okay he
was but not you
kind of sicko the answer to all of these
he suggests is the same no reason no
reason no reason absolutely no reason
why did the second oldest boy in malcolm
in the middle' never have a family no
reason why did the moon never receive an
email from his favorite ball of gas no
reason why did I get five more but I'll
stop you know as Goofy's this opening is
I'm not gonna lie I really feel like he
belongs at the beginning of a much more
appropriate movie witness fit a lot more
with something like the film you were
about to see today is in homage to the
no reason Alvin and the Chipmunks
wouldn't that weirdly make a lot more
sense so after putting the pretend and
pretentious we see he was talking to a
group of people who are given binoculars
to watch the movie I guess it's already
born well I could guess what movie they
were watching as the credits roll and we
see birth finally had enough with Ernie
shit we finally see the title but more
importantly we see the directors credit
immediately after the title yeah he
wants you to know what movie you're
watching but he especially wants you to
know who to blame for it oh wait I've
seen this it travels across the world
connects to other parts and puts the
Iron Giant back together again and they
say split was a surprise sequel the tire
seems to learn how to live suddenly and
starts moving on its own now the tire
continues to move around but is having
trouble keeping his balance thus moving
around like he's being controlled by a
Wii Remote he comes across his first
antagonist in the movie though a water
bottle murderer he then comes across a
scorpion it's gonna be a long movie
isn't it he then comes across a beer
bottle which he can't seem to crush so
he uses his psychokinetic powers to blow
it up yeah Tigers have those now
the TSA's minor trail of nuisance
continues the on lookers comment on what
they're seeing looks like he has
telepathic powers
you mean psychokinetic I don't care
about the right word I think the kid is
right psychokinetic powers excuse me but
you have to come in everything allowed
yeah so the tire continues to roll and
blows up a can this time Allen man I'm
not getting much from the tires
performance but he does still give more
emotion than Kristen Stewart whoo things
are getting really exciting because now
we have a musical score you clearly
missed a perfect opportunity to play a
more fitting song
[Music]
but it looks like he's tired it's not
worth as he rests and guess up the next
morning to continue his travels well
that happened meanwhile we see how this
film was financed with one of the guys
in charge stealing from one of the
viewers let's go
where is he straight ahead I just woke
up okay just tell me is this the cabin
in the woods universe is the tire just
one of the killer monsters that escaped
and the onlookers are just monitoring
the progress I'd have makes thoughts but
it's better than no thoughts
look the tire is drinking water you know
it's the weirdest things that leave you
empty he finally comes across a living
mammal and tests his powers on it what
the hell
[Music]
odd musical choice for an odd segment
you know this movie is feeling less like
a horror film and more like an
old-school Miller Lite commercial you
worked hard had a long week and are
celebrating your best friend blowing up
a rabbit your best friend is a tire now
more than ever it's Miller time because
you work hard you play hard and that
tire can turn your brain to spaghetti
sauce
Miller because if you're watching a
killer tire you're probably drunk
already a woman tries buying a
convertible catching the tires attention
I shall free you my manacled brethren it
was run over by dr. gonzo and his
attorney we can't stop here this is
Firestone Country she continues to drive
on as the tire comes across a guy at a
gas station what's the most you ever
lost in a coin toss for endo oh my god I
hope you like that if not how did Peter
Venkman put it you only have 75 more to
go wait that tire matches the
description turn around he comes across
a hotel where a part of me is hoping
he'll reenact psycho as the onlookers
continue to bring the annoyance of
watching a movie at a theater to the
comfort of your home come on can't you
take a little joke yeah oh there's
plenty of space go somewhere else if
we're bothering you why do I feel like
these people were conned by Nathan
fielder I promised these people an
interactive movie experience without
movie theater hassles but I had no
interactive movie to show so I kept them
at a safe distance and said it was about
a killer tire I feel like I could only
get away with this in California
fear not though it gets weirder
[Laughter]
working his or rollbacks it's a
personally hard to think of a joke about
a tire in a hotel room watching workout
videos meanwhile in the same hotel one
of the guys running the show is given a
call oh yes master I understand
perfectly I'm gonna do it tomorrow
morning without fail
so just to recap a guy in a hotel gets a
call from the master well he has a
turkey in his room well I for one think
it's about time a man knows Thanksgiving
wings of fate finally got aired God how
do I have an easier time coming up with
that joke than this one the next morning
after a few days without eating the
onlookers are given the roasted carcass
of poultry Geist Christ it's like 3 p.m.
at the Old Country Buffet a staff member
seems to interrupt the tyres shower oh
they didn't tell me there was nudity in
this and big shock the tire does not
take this with Goodyear humor well she's
a maid so she can clean herself up the
tire then watches TV and checks out the
woman in the pool you think his
fascination with humans has seen a
strange to others like is this interest
made fun of by other tires hey you see
Carl recently yeah I hear he's into that
people stuff you think he's a human
years he has to be oh wait here he comes
hey Carl
so you get on having sex with humans or
something you know it's true man
actually that's a common misconception
not all humans want to have sex with
humans some of us enjoy the creative
lifestyle designs an overall environment
you have sex with humans
you got sick oh yeah
why do I forget you can do that
do you find the Michelin tire guy sexy
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody is after you I have no idea if
that's true I never even met you but
going by statistics of online crime
someone probably is there's a lot of
snoops and hackers out there and you
want to be careful and you want to be
smart that's why it's good to use
Express VPN like me you can feel safe
knowing that your information is
protected trust me you need a VPN
because without it your information can
be tracked by ISP cellular providers and
companies and hackers when you use a VPN
though your public IP is masked so even
the websites you visit won't be able to
identify you but also trust me when I
say expressvpn is the best VPN it has
the fastest speeds faster than any other
VPN provider server locations in over
ninety four countries giving you plenty
of options to choose from 24/7 customer
service whenever you need it
apps for every device including Windows
iOS Android Mac Linux router and even
more and it's easy to use you can
connect with just one click
it has the best-in-class encryption 256
bit AES and it's the market weeding VPN
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar this is such an important item
to get and this is such a good company
to get it from and you can for less than
seven dollars a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box expressvpn comm
slash nostalgia critic that's expr ESS
VPN comm slash nostalgia critic for
three months free with a one-year
package so what are you waiting for get
what you know you need visit expressvpn
comm slash nostalgia critic to learn
more take back your privacy today
[Music]
so the son of the owner of the hotel
says he saw a tire close one of the
doors the owner doesn't believe him and
commands he gets him a pizza and don't
forget the double toppings I like the
idea of making a kid's punishment your
reward he seems to come across this
totally pointless hitchhiker guy whoa
well that's just rude clearly two people
can fit on that bike
say here's some double toppings
double-talking stop doing my jokes the
tire meanwhile falls in the pool and the
onlookers seem to get sick from the food
they ate a poisonous Turkey was a trap
do I take it this is where a tire bursts
out of one of their stomachs don't worry
ma'am they're not gonna get away with it
I'm still here god bless you want Walker
doing whatever it is you're doing for
whatever reason you're doing it ooh more
toppings
[Music]
did she just put orange juice on her
breakfast did anybody watch this film
while they were making it this tires
alive he'd locked okay you know what
I've heard enough rubbish for the day
all right now get that dirty tire out of
the pool or I'm gonna get really mad and
there's not nearly enough bird guts on
this pizza to make it edible meanwhile
the cop from the beginning of the movie
seems to ask the same WTF nests as
before don't you find it strange we
can't see the air around us don't you
think it's weird we're not giving
refunds to the viewers of this movie but
in a very odd turn yeah I know what I
said the cap says the poison has had
enough time to kill the spectators and
so everyone can stop everyone however
has no idea what he's talking about you
know I'll go home to your families now
you're out of your mind stop acting like
this is real life I'm telling you we're
done there's no one watching anymore
okay moviegoers have clearly left the
theater by now there's no point in
continuing he tries to prove it by
having somebody shoot him and it has no
effect it's not real you understand you
know if you just slap these two names on
the title this would have the biggest
cult following in the world the cop is
told though that one of the on lookers
is still alive because he didn't eat
which apparently means the film has to
keep going so he returns to question the
owner of the hotel okay either Deadpool
directed this movie or this is bad
lieutenant three I'm fine with either
just pick one or both it just give me
something the tire finds a mirror and
thinks back to the glory days
[Music]
sometimes you just gotta ask yourself
how can I see my reflection with no lies
or what's this hole I feel in my body or
maybe um when should I retire what am I
supposed to do with this the boy sees
the tire and tries to figure out what's
going on
do you talk me fumin boy hey answer me
so how was your day son well I went to
school asked a girl out and then
demanded to tire to talk to me took you
off those meds too soon so the cop gives
an idea for the suspect they're looking
for this is what our killer looks like
tire exactly I'm honestly shocked they
didn't utilize their sketch artist for
this one one of the cats though has a
question is it black that didn't happen
it just felt good the cops find a tire
and stop right behind him
not getting out the car because I don't
know you want to know how I got these
skid marks let me take a wild guess what
happens I should have put that together
one of the guys running things tries to
poison the last unlocker but he refuses
to eat so the other guy does huh okay
stuff was supposed to be for you to eat
Suicide Squad from Life of Brian was
easier to take out than you he sees a
burning tire pile and goes absolutely
insane because over the next three days
he goes on a killing spree
he gives a ton of people the skander
treatment and then watches I guess his
version of the Olympics one of the cops
finds the tire though as they let the
guy in charge know who's apparently
playing chess you can't do that really
well you can if you want but it's
against the rules
that's good to know that this film
graduated from the Freddy got fingered
school of advertising we know we don't
know what we're doing
get a load of this they're actually
attempting to Woody Woodpecker his ass
come on this scene makes no sense at all
so the onlooker comes around and says
the scene makes no sense about doing my
job
the onlooker suggests that just shooting
the tire will end the movie faster but
one of the cops brings up this good
point yeah but then we wouldn't be here
if you'd eaten a damn turkey that's true
enough you saw some Looney Tunes cartoon
written by Charlie Kaufman so in I have
to admit maybe my favorite anti
climactic death of any movie monster the
cop goes in saying he's just gonna blow
him away
shoots him off-screen and then throws
the carcass on the onlooker and by
that's like in Halloween if Michael
Myers went out like this he blowed up
exit 2 you're right I have to admire
what a slap in the face that is but
there's a twist in this ending I guess
it comes back as a tricycle and blows up
the onlooker hey baby
he's off to play invisible paperboy as
he's apparently gathered to tire army to
follow him and that seems to be it ok so
on the whole I can't act like it was oh
there's more like several minutes more
the final image I guess is the tricycle
and his dawn of the tread heading to
Hollywood the credits also show the cop
giving the intro speech again only this
time it's too literally nobody yet he
still doesn't word for word why do some
people love sausages and other people I
hate sausages no fucking reason call me
crazy but I didn't take a movie about a
killer tire with require returned the
King number endings come on don't waste
your time explaining that garbage so
let's go just a minute
let me finish da shoe and I was hoping
the final image would be Woody Harrelson
with flaming red hair saying there will
be carnage what the burning rubber did I
just watch on the one hand I guess I can
see why some people didn't like it
of questions about this world are raised
and are never answered and it even seems
like some of the jokes are set up and no
real punchlines are delivered but as the
film clearly states in the opening it
has no reason if anything it kind of
feels like a troll film it still us
laughs it still has gore it still has a
killer tire it just doesn't really care
much on the story's overviews is to have
much of one it's almost like the movie
focus is on the spectacle of such a
crazy idea rather than the crazy idea
itself but you could argue some horror
films already do without even
acknowledging it I kind of like that so
yeah if you look at this less like a
human centipede kind of dumb and more
like an artsy return to killer Tomatoes
kind of dumb I think you'll get a fun
experience it's weird it's silly it
makes little sense but it gave a tyre
killing people and a few surreal laughs
I guess what the kind of film it is
that's enough for me to say roll on in
and enjoy so that's it another nostalgia
weena McCann next week I'm back to my
normal reviews and I had to admit though
I didn't really get a monster movie that
made me really mad like super super mad
oh don't worry critic after next week's
review we've got one that'll hurt you
[Music]
you don't actually have a movie do you
know I just wanted the last line of the
review great what terrible movie you're
gonna say we found hi I'm a dinosaur I
just made a sculpture
it's called King dumb oh no my fallen
kingdom now those are my cruise the
Phantom
[Music]
you
in the excellent Chainsaw Massacre by
tobe Hooper why don't we ever see the
characters go to the bathroom hey folks
Doug Walker here doing the charity shout
out and this week the charity ties in to
our what you can do video which is
Friends of the forest we went to this
Forest Preserve where a ton of people
showed up and they were just helping the
forest look great and you know protect
the wildlife there and just a lot of
cool people and they were nice and
they're having fun and they were joking
around and it was really really cool it
was so nice just getting together and
seeing all these people sort of come
around and do something that's so good
for you know people in the environment
and it was just a nice nice group and
we're promoting them today so what we're
gonna show is a snippet of the video
from other what you can do video which
shows how you can volunteer but you can
also donate either are welcome like I
said this is a really wonderful
organization they're so cool and you
definitely got check them out which
you're going to write here check them
out my name is Rhonda comer alia I work
for Friends of the horse preserves and
we support the restoration and
engagement efforts of the forest
preserves of Cook County my name is Jeff
screen II and one of the volunteers that
works for the horse preserve and I'm one
of the leaders here at labahn woods and
what are you doing today we're planting
ninety six locally grown native shrubs
to replace shrubs that we've lost due to
invasive species Friends of the forest
preserves was established 20 years ago
we're celebrating our 20th anniversary
this year I see yeah we are a small
nonprofit grassroots group that saw a
need to get more support for the first
reserves of Cook County and their
initiatives to help restore the health
of the forest preserves we offer
different ways of engaging people so if
you're not ready to jump in and get your
hands dirty and cut down evasive species
we also like to work with people to get
them out canoeing or hiking the
kinds of educational events and all
supporting the forest reserves of Cook
County's mission to engage people in the
enjoyment of natural areas in the area
you always hear a lot of people say it's
important to look after forest preserves
and the environment
what's a reason to do this that people
usually overlook or they don't think
about the forest preserves in the city
for habitat or home for a great
diversity of plants and animals that you
wouldn't expect to find in a city
environment what it does for your help
to get in the forest is very important
but we know that there's 1,000 different
species that we've had logged here that
live here this is their home and they
were here before us a lot of volunteers
showed us today well over 50 people I
think showed up to this you sound like
they kind of come from different groups
and organizations and stuff like that
what's the process there the various
organizations that are involved we all
communicate regularly about what's going
on and try to work collaboratively we
all have the same goal of trying to
conserve nature and engage people with
nature our main goal is we want people
to come out and have a good time we
recognize everybody is a volunteer and
volunteers want to have fun they don't
want to come out and feel like they work
their butts off like too much or that it
was like a job when we have a group like
this it's a big group today you said 50
some people no one's gonna have to do
too much and everybody's gonna feel like
they had a great day and made a
difference well if people want to
volunteer or donate or find out anything
more about Friends of the forest I want
you to look right in that camera and
tell where they can go online
fo TF P dot o-r-g or friends of the
horse preserves if you want a go good
awesome thank you guys so much thank you
thank you thank you for coming are you
doing
you
[Music]